CapSense is a single volume soft haptic
input/output device that provides
integrated and simultaneous contact
force sensing and vibrant tactile
feedback. Since we have information about
the driving waveform magnitude, we can
carry out concurrent pressure sensing by
monitoring the voltage across HapSense.
Our device system fully supports
portability, where HapSense can even
be operated with a small lithium polymer
battery. HapSense is a ferroelectric
polymer actuator which can operate at
relatively low voltage compared to
existing software actuators, which we
introduce a low-temperature fabrication
process to allow HCI practitioners to
build their own soft haptic input/output
devices. Conductive electrode patterns
were manually screen printed on the
prepared PVDF film. Patterned adhesive
film was applied to form a single unit
study 25 units were stacked on each
other. We carried out thorough
electromechanical characterizations to
ensure HapSense's performance as an
actuator and a sensor. We demonstrate
example applications where we highlight
a single volume soft interface that can
provide simultaneous haptic sensing
capability. HapSense can be attached to a
syringes plunger to train users to
maintain a constant injection rate. By
sensing the applied force on the plunger,
vibrotactile feedback with distinctive
waveforms can be provided to correct the
users injection rate.
When controlling a virtual object, it is
not often clear whether input commands
have been processed or missed. HapSense can
vibrate when a user successfully execute
a tap or press gesture to select a 3d
model in a mixed reality environment.
Multiple HapSense prototypes can be
configured to support private and
ice-free interactions. In this example,
users get macro-level vibration from a
phone. By placing their hands on the
prototype, users can acquire detailed
information through spatio-temporal
vibration patterns. We devised 2x2 arrays
of HapSense to configure a haptic
notification panel. Users can acquire
information from specific software
applications such as the calendar app by
placing their hand on different
locations of multiple HapSense
prototypes. Input commands can be
executed simultaneously by simply
pressing different regions of the system.
HapSense can be adapted to various
mounting surfaces including uneven
profiles with soft and flexible material
properties. The furniture's armrests can
be used as both a remote controller and
a smartphone-connected vibration panel.
We can embed HapSense on various soft
surfaces, such as a smartphone case, due
to its low profile and soft form. Adding
a soft input/output device onto a
smartphone case will not only add
sensing functionality, but also localized
vibrotactile feedback.
By augmenting contact sensing with
integrated vibrotactile feedback we hope
to expand and improve the means of
interactions with soft input/output
devices.